et
[Musique]
la cosmo l'une va partir au dernier
moment les shadoks à grosse tête ont
pris la direction des opérations et ont
obligé les responsables à pompe et à
leur place
[Musique]
c'est ainsi qu'au matin il ya bien
longtemps la lune et les shadoks
quittèrent la terre cahin caha temps
pour aller mon principe vers l'infini et
même plus loin si c'était possible il
quitter sans aucun regret une terre qui
était loin de leur avoir procuré d'un
taux de satisfaction est la terre les
dix partis de la même façon le train
interstellaire shadoks comportait
premièrement un module en forme de cosmo
autobus ou les shadoks à grosse tête
faisait des calculs derrière venaient la
lune qui servait des tâches propulseur
par le truchement du tchador tu te 20
boutiques du professeur tad au cours de
route
tout cela est parfait et au moins de
rien le drain shadoks kit l'orbité
terrestre pour se placer sur la
trajectoire de voyage de forme
approximativement shadow koïta à ce
moment là comme vous le savez il est
d'usagé en astronautique de se
débarrasser de laitages propulseurs qui
pratiquement ne sert plus à rien les
shadoks à grosse tête sont parfaitement
au courant de tout ça et c'était un
rafiot tu lui la route tous les tâches
propulseur évidemment rue chine proteste
il n'allait tout de même pas les laisser
en plan perdu là en plein milieu de
l'espace c'était pas humain c'est la
technique c'est la technique mais voilà
condamnés à mourir ici le tout au moins
à y rester jusqu'à la fin des
[Musique]
mais depuis le temps qu'il faisait
pompes et les autres après tout d'un
coup ils n'ont que ce qu'ils méritent et
notre histoire de ce point de vue là ce
n'est pas tellement une morale que ça
pendant ce temps là sur la terre les
jours passaient et comme son usage et
néjib y continuer à vieillir
et un jour même certains failli mourir
alors l'egypte y compris qu'il y avait
encore sur la terre un problème qu'il
n'avait pas résolu qu'il fallait faire
quelque chose mais vite sans quoi des
gis be in een on aurait bientôt plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]